[Musique]
après le déjeuner en débarrasse la table
on met les restes dans la poubelle la
poubelle dans la rue
tiens t'as pas où et quand on se voit
josé bauer maintenant il me les jours
comme ça mais qu'est ce que vous faites
non mais ça va pas et enfin vous n'êtes
pas généré évidemment ça attire les
crédos chien toujours la recherche à nos
noces et je vais voilà bah tiens ça
donne des idées aux autres
[Musique]
tout le monde fait pareil pollueurs
encore un mais que fait-il mais il met
le feu
[Musique]
on voit tout tu es là c'est quelque
chose dans ses plis
[Musique]
ah non vous n'allez pas recommencer tout
de même
- produits
des charges interdite c'est compris
[Musique]
à
bon maintenant retrouvons les autres
podiums puisque vous avez sali
maintenant il va falloir nettoyer
aller au travail et que tout cela
disparaisse ensuite les ordures que l'on
a récupéré on les emporte dans une usine
là elles sont soigneusement brûlé
et ça ne laisse pas de trace
la campagne quand même plus belle comme
ça non
si vous voulez vraiment faire plaisir à
watou fait encore un petit effort à la
place de la décharge sauvage arranger
l'endroit pour que les gens viennent
pique-niquer propre vent
[Musique]
hu
revoir au revoir voit tous à tous merci
où
m